bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on est avec
paul qui a une start up qui s'appelle le
jeune paul ce que nous en parler parce
que vraiment c'est un truc qui est top
bien sûr donc que j'aime
peter de khobar convient fixé à
proximité de sa poubelle de cuisine
seront bien trier mieux consommer et
faire ses courses le concept est très
simple pour l'avenir en fait scanner le
code barre de son emballage avant de le
jeter et eugène com - michel labonne
consulte de triche
nitrique qui est géolocalisé et détaillé
les consignes de tri peuvent varier
d'une ville à l'autre
donc ça en fin de compte ça marche
directement avec le code le code barre
du produit
ouais et une visée que vous avez un
partenariat avec les c'est ça on peut
être le principe aussi c'est de venir
récompenser l'utilisateur pour son reste
de triche chaque fois que vous scannez
un emballage vous allez gagner des
points
les points pour être convertir en bons
de réduction bons d'achat chez un
certain nombre de partenaires
chaque produit et scannés et enregistrés
dans votre historique de consommation ça
nous permet donc de l'analyse et de
suivre votre consommation au jour le
jour
le voir les
de trouver des produits qui vous
correspondent en fonction de vos
critères environnementaux des allergènes
les ingrédients etc
si je mange des trucs trop sucrés je
pourrais voir et dire ah ça j'en ai trop
manger pour ce recensement exactement le
même but de co kg d'une loi des années
savent qu'elles sont aussi les produits
qui contiennent du gluten on déguste de
palme par exemple dans mon alimentation
et les dernières fonctions c'est comme
un produit je t ai souvent
un produit qu'on a besoin de racheter
l'application permet de créer vos styles
de cours et 7/10 de pauvres pouvaient
l'utiliser soit en magasin comme une
check list à ne plus rien oublié
finalement soit l'envoyer directement
dans le panier en ligne votre
distributeur d'accord donc ça permet
d'acheter en ligne le
mieux trier oui de mieux consommer parce
qu'on a un vrai retour sur l'historique
acte et je me disais qu'ils aussi une
gamification gagne des points où aller
remis
c'est ça ouais en fait l'un des deux
trains
au développement du tri sélectif c'est
le manque d'informations sur comment
recycler et le manque d'incitation
concrètes à faire le bon geste à l'égard
des principaux la cédraie compenser
l'utilisateur avec des pointes de
transformer en bons d'achat en
récompense de même faire un don à
l'association
voilà pour l'inciter
alors c'est quoi le l'idée de base de ça
c'est quoi c'est un con ça c'est à vous
rendre compte que y'avait pas
nécessairement boutique avec étriers
correctement ouais bah en fait le
concept dépassé qui à l'ensemble des
français qui se dit favorable au tri
tout le monde d'y créer c'est bien c'est
voilà c'est le jeu c'est le premier
geste environnemental des français est
pourtant dans la pratique n'a seulement
un sur quatre qui le fait correctement
au quotidien d'accord il ya beaucoup
d'erreurs de très cher d'ailleurs aux
collectivités locales et dans le même
temps les consommateurs plus en plus
exigeants et et y attendre des marques
et distributeurs un meilleur
accompagnement pour une démarche plus
citoyenne plus responsable on parle
voilà j'ai eu de plus en plus d'
illégale
c'est important c'est important un
danger pour l'avenir des états unis que
ça d'accord qualité dans
j'ai quand même temps vous travaillez
sur le jeune homme a créé le gène en mai
3 manquons
développent leur produit et développe
des partenariats et aujourd'hui
à commercialiser le produit il est
disponible en précommande sur le site
internet
jamais le lien en descriptions regardez
c'est parfait à 79 euros
la livraison est garantie sous 30 jours
est disponible à partir du camp
disponible va là on peut déjà pris
médiation on a immédiatement et la
livraison est prévue pour début octobre
est ce que c'est vrai que c'est vrai
qu'on regarde un produit comme celui là
qui est un produit grande distribution
ce qu'on voit au niveau du recyclage
on voit bien moi c'est vrai que je ne
comprends pas trop du coup je m'emmerde
maintenant c'est le problème c'est que
c'est
c'est rarement été sur le sol par kddi
et
c'est écrit c'est aussi notre hymne
national alors que les consignes de tri
varie d'une ville à l'autre des corps
noircis à la ronde israël d'accord ok
donc davantage avec un an digitalise ans
est consignes de tri c'est de pouvoir
l'adapter à l'endroit où vous vivez donc
ça c'est un produit qui est disponible
du coup via une application qu'on peut
utiliser qui est joie sur l'appstore et
sur google plaide donc android et
android et ios et ios ok facile de prise
en main facile de prise en main on a une
belle motif qu'ils veulent explique bien
comment ça fonctionne et qui est
labellisé fasse l'écho
écoute je te remercie pour toutes les
informations je souhaite bon courage
parce que vraiment c'est un produit qui
qui à la fois écologique qui permet de
faire un tri correctement qui correct le
français se fait ça sera mieux qui
permet aux civils après d'avoir une
liste d'achats pour faire ses courses de
l'envoyer lorsqu'on va les passer au
drive tonnes la gamification enfin il ya
que dès que des avantages et c'est un
produit qui à mon avis il faut il faut
posséder
assez rapidement pour trier correctement
et puis ça vous solutionne tous pour
pour la vie quoi c'est mal français
merci beaucoup mais tellement aux
commentaires du poids tout ce que vous
en pensez ce que vous faites du tri we
know est ce que vous pensez je vais
faire correctement est un produit comme
celui-là vous paraît intéressant vous
marquez tout ça et puis bon moment en
tout cas je vais la laisser plus en
détails merci beaucoup à bientôt
la frayeur voir la lune
[Musique]